[Music]
the world of sound that is created by so
many musicians is so strong that you get
goosebumps
[Applause]
you get slaps on your face and punching
the stomach it's very very intense and
powerful i'm not really able to
translate it into words you just have to
see it
[Music]
my name is fabi zaffanini and i'm the
founder of rocky 1000 the biggest rock
band on earth
rocky 1000 is a band composed of
thousands and thousands of musicians
coming from all over the world
we organize massive events where more
than a thousand musicians perform
simultaneously
we have 400 guitars 250 drummers
300 bassists 350 singers
we have musicians coming from 30
different countries in the world from
south korea from united states from
canada from brazil russia iran
the logistic challenge is quite big
hundreds and hundreds of people built
the stage which is as big as a football
field
we have hundreds of microphones miles
and miles of wires and cables it's crazy
all the musicians have to prepare from
home and once they come here they will
have like three days of rehearsals very
intense days
they get to meet each other they start
playing and
meld together and build the magic
[Music]
the main message behind rocky 1000 is
the spirit of togetherness
the idea that people that generally play
in their basement or sing under the
shower when they're all together they
can really make the difference and it's
a message that goes far beyond music i
think
we make no difference of the sexual
orientation political orientation
religious orientations rich or poor
professionals or newbies we include
everybody they're all together because
of rock and roll
[Music]
[Music]
you